Welcome back everyone
It's Charlie
Mark Ruffalo was talking about the new Hulk movie
he's been working on
for the past few years at Marvel
and why it's taken so long to actually get it made.
So we'll break it all down, but it finally sounds like
they're actually doing something about it.
In the wheels of bureaucracy
have just been turning extremely slow,
If you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos.
They're also releasing a bunch of Marvel and Star Wars
shows on
Blu rays recently from Disney Plus,
like they're finally doing the Blu rays.
So we'll give away a couple of copies
between now and Christmas.
We got the
what if season two episodes coming up real soon, too.
Hulk will be a big part of those.
it seems like he might be in a couple episodes,
but the trailer footage shows him in
what looks like the 1602 episode,
so I'll talk about that at the end of the video.
They got a bunch of Hulk related stuff happening,
especially in
Captain America four,
which is going to be coming out in 2025. Now.
But recently, Mark Ruffalo is promoting his new movie
Poor Things and talked about all these Hulk solo movie
things that apparently Marvel told him
he's not supposed to talk about giving
that full spoiler bro's energy Once a spoiler, bro.
Always a spoiler, bro.
This is the clip of him talking about that Hulk movie
he's been working on I got to ask you about the Hulk.
NBC Universal and Disney recently made a deal for Hulu.
We know the Hulk movie rights for a standalone picture
have been kind of complicated.
Has that changed anything?
And I've been asked not to comment on it
that specifically.
I mean, hopefully one day,
though, they'll work it out.
And I think it would be
I think it could be really cool.
And I've been putting a lot of thought
into what it could be to be cool.
so the way he talks about it, he's got that next
Hulk movie figured out for the most part.
And the only thing that's still holding them up
from actually rolling cameras on it
is the ongoing legal problems
between Marvel, Disney and Universal.
the main problem
he references is that Universal's contract
for the Hulk characters is really specific.
it basically gives them the first rights of refusal
to release,
like distribute any Hulk movie of any kind
with any Hulk related characters
That basically means
that Hulk has to be in the title of the movie.
Like this is the chart of the characters that it gives
them control over, but it's only for the movies.
Notice how Marvel controls most of most of their
characters with like the little bubble here for Sony.
In all, the Spider-Man sharing stuff
that they have going on for the past several years.
even though it seems like universal
controls are the Hulk characters,
it's only for the movies,
like I said, not for the TV shows.
That's
why Marvel was able to release the She-Hulk episodes
and put the Bruce Banner
Hulk in Scar, Son of Hulk during that.
that's the main reason why Kevin Feige
has only been using Hulk in big Avengers
movies or big crossover movies as a smaller character
like Thor Ragnarok because his name isn't
in the title of the movie, so it doesn't fall under
that universal contract so they're basically
taking Big Hulk stories and like breaking them up
and putting them in a bunch of other movies
or like breaking them across several different movies.
so there is a universal
doesn't have the rights to make a whole movie.
They just have the rights to distribute
a finished fourth movie in Disney.
Marvel don't want to give them all the money that
they would earn from releasing any kind of Hulk movie.
the Spider-Man deal gives Marvel
the rights to actually make the Spider-Man movie.
Sony just takes a big, big percentage
of the box office profits,
and they have a big say in
what happens during that movie.
So the idea that Mark Ruffalo keeps talking about
and he says this in most of his interviews
where he talks about Hulk movie related stuff
until Marvel works out a deal with Universal,
like until the lawyers get done slap
fighting each other, they won't actually start filming
that next Hulk solo movie.
but it sounds like they basically
had the storyboard it, a lot of the shows and movies
they've been doing now recently in
They have coming up in the next couple of years, help
set that Hulk solo movie up.
you might remember Mark Ruffalo talking about this
Hulk solo movie a couple of years ago.
Like he's been working on this for a long, long time.
usually when people refer to that next Hulk solo movie,
they just keep calling it World War Hulk.
It wouldn't be the exact same comic book version
of that story, but they're using a lot of elements
from that story in current Marvel movies right
now, Mostly Captain America
for Brave New World in the She-Hulk
Post-Credits scene with Scar, Son of Hulk.
a lot of people wondered why they would introduce
Hulk Son from the Planet Hulk storyline.
All of a sudden,
they didn't really reference that during the events
of Thor Ragnarok, and that was largely
based on the events of Planet Hulk,
the whole idea is that there was this missing
period of time, like about a two year period of time
that Hulk was only Hulk
and Banner's personality was subsumed
in really wasn't aware that much of what Hulk was doing
for that whole time period.
in that was when Scar, Son of Hulk was conceived
and eventually born.
that's why Banner was able to come out
during the events of Thor Ragnarok
not knowing that Scar existed.
but a lot of people at the time of this She-Hulk
post-credits scene are like, Is this for young Avengers
set up?
Like, is Scar going to be on that team?
The Kamala Khan's Miss Marvel is putting together?
More recently we saw is he going to be in Captain
America four as part of the Red Hulk Thunderbolt
Ross storyline At the time,
the report is that they introduced Scar
with the intention of paying off his storyline
in the next Hulk solo movie.
Like Way Further Down the Road.
Mark Ruffalo said that he'll keep playing the Bruce
Banner Hulk as long as Marvel will have him, too.
But I think part of the idea is that
they're building out the Hulk universe of characters
from the comics wanting to go deeper on the Hulk family
in future movies and TV shows,
it It's not like they're going to put Mark Ruffalo's
Bruce Banner Hulk in
like ten different movies and series
all at the same time.
So you just need more of those Hulk related characters
that's why they're finally doing Thunderbolt.
Ross read Hulk during Captain America four.
They kind of set that storyline even starting
as far back
as the Incredible
Hulk Edward Norton version of the movie
I want what's inside.
all the people that made that movie, even Edward
Norton said that originally it was supposed to be
a trilogy of movies like The Leader was going to be
the main villain of the second movie.
but that was when Marvel had other people
distributing their films
before Disney started doing all that themselves.
I think part of the idea is that by the time
they got to that third Hulk solo movie,
that's when Thunderbolt Ross would have become Red Hook
and he would have been the main villain of that film.
ba. Like they just introduced
She-Hulk, now scarred son of Hulk.
they also just released a scene
showing that they brought back Liv Tyler's Betty Ross
from the Edward Norton Incredible
Hulk movie for Captain America four.
She's here at a funeral scene
that Sam Wilson's new Falcon, Captain America is at
the funeral
might be like a fake outdone by Thunderbolt Ross.
And that's why she's come.
Because it's a funeral for her father.
We know that they're turning him into Red Hulk
during the movie.
He's going to be played by Harrison Ford.
They've recast the character,
but it's still meant to be the original version
of the character in there is a lot a lot of Hulk
related stuff happening in Captain America four.
Like The Leader is also back from the Incredible
Hulk movie, supposed to be the main villain,
if not one of the main villains.
He's got green hands and all the behind the scenes.
So it seems that they're going for comic book leader
with him to
he'll probably be the one to turn Thunderbolt
Ross into Red Hulk.
he was part of the intelligentsia group in the comics
that turn Thunderbolt Ross into Red
Hook in the comics as well, too,
which came out of the World War Hulk storyline.
But here's the thing.
Even though there's all this Hulk stuff
happening in the movie,
the main conflict isn't going to be Hulk versus
Red Hook.
It's still going to be like
the new Falcon version of Captain America versus
what seems like Red
Hulk all the Bruce Banner related Hulk stuff.
Just seems like it's happening in the background.
They're also supposed to be paying off
What happens with that giant dead celestial
from the Eternals movie team
and who's been just chilling out in the Indian Ocean
on the other side of the world this whole time
that's supposed to set up this Adamantium MCU plot it.
They haven't changed anything leading into weapon
X, the new MCU Wolverine down the road related stuff.
not the Hugh Jackman version of Wolverine in Deadpool
three or Avengers six Secret wars.
Like I think this time
it adamantium celestial related stuff won't be too like
Marvel Phase seven boots are slowly start
setting that up in the background.
So at least right now it just
sounds like they're using a lot of the Captain America
four storyline to further the Bruce Banner
Hulk story, eventually culminating that
in what would be the next Hulk solo movie
like a World War Hulk type of movie down the road.
my early theory right now about why Hulk would go off
the chain so hardcore that the rest of the heroes
of the world, even the villains,
would all band together to try and stop him.
would have to have something
to do with his son, Scar of Hulk.
Like if his life was threatened,
that might cause him to lose control
because the whole thing like they show during SHIELD,
he is like super Zen now.
Like what would cause him to completely lose control?
I think they tried to tease that a little bit
during She-Hulk, like they fought a little bit
during that first episode.
But it still seems like he is totally Zen right now.
Like something would have to happen to scar for him
to completely lose control.
my early assumption right now is that
unless something really big changes behind the scenes
with Marvel and Universal the next couple of years,
we probably won't see that next Hulk solo movie
until after Avengers
six Secret Wars sometime during Marvel Phase seven.
But here's the thing.
As much as that sucks, that means that we will be able
to see a Hulk versus Wolverine movie, too, because
by that time we'll have all the core X-Men characters,
we'll have all the Fantastic Four characters.
so they also want to make a mini Avengers movie of it
and do like a bigger World War Hulk style movie.
They can actually do a more comic book
accurate version of that with the century character,
with the Fantastic Four, with him
spanking all the X-Men characters.
Eddie way harder for them to do that if they were to do
that solo Hulk movie before Secret Wars.
ba. Let me know in the comments
what kind of stories and characters
you want to see in that next Hulk solo movie?
the other real big reminder is in a couple of weeks
we'll get the what if season two episodes.
Like I said, all the trailer footage of Hulk
seems like it's from the 1602 episode
but he might be in a couple episodes
during the 1602 comics, he was actually a supporter
of the throne at the time of King James, the first
he was the successor of Queen Elizabeth.
but here's the thing.
I think they're doing a slightly different version
of 1602 for the what if season
two episode in, they're going to go full meta with it,
saying that Hella is actually ruling over either
Great Britain or the world
because Cate Blanchett played both Helena in the MCU
and she played a version of Queen Elizabeth,
the first and Queen Elizabeth the first reign
basically ended around the time
1602 began in the comics.
So you have Cate Blanchett giving a lot of Queen
Elizabeth the first energy
and hella energy at the same time.
The circle of Easter Eggs is now complete.
all sort naming giveaway winners
in my next couple of Marvel videos, too,
Just periodically throughout the next couple of weeks,
I'll just keep the giveaway running through all my
What if season 2 episodes do everyone click here
for that new Deadpool three and Wolverine video
with all the X-Men and click here for that
brand new Blade trailer video.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe and I'll see you guys the next one!